es ist eine nacht die die moderne türkei
verändert hat am abend des 15
juli 2016 putschen teile des militärs
besetzenden istanbul die erste
bosporusbrücke der präsident ruft das
volk auf die straße
tausende folgen stellen sich den panzern
entgegen es gibt tote auf beiden seiten
der putsch versuch ist gescheitert
präsident erdogan macht die anhänger
seines politischen gegenspielers des
islam prediger fethullah gülen
verantwortlich und erschwert bittere
rache
wir werden dieses virus das sich in
allen staatlichen institutionen
verbreitet hat ausmerzen
sofort beginnt eine beispiellose
säuberungswelle die bis heute anhält
zehntausende soldaten richter lehrer
werden verhaftet oder entlassen
auch jo de gaulle und ihr mann hussain
gehören dazu
beide sind lehrer werden monate nach dem
putschversuch gefeiert vom präsidenten
per dekret wir sind keine terroristen
meint judith kühl sondern linke
gewerkschafter oppositionelle
doch wir ahnten was passieren wird am
abend des putschversuchs hatten wir
große angst denn auf jedem pott in der
türkischen geschichte folgte ein angriff
auf die linke linke wurden damals
festgenommen oder wurden arbeitslos
heute zahlen wir dafür den preis mit
privaten nachhilfeunterricht halten sie
sich heute über wasser für das regime
sind sie feinde
sie stehen auf einer schwarzen liste
haben keine chance je wieder im
öffentlichen dienst zu arbeiten
heute fünf jahre später sagt jo de
gaulle herrscht in ihrem land eine
atmosphäre der angst wir werden
unterdrückt leben in einem umfeld das
uns ständig mit arbeitslosigkeit und
ausgrenzung quellen
es ist wie eine folter sie machen uns
das leben zur hölle
auch der journalist bühne sitzt nach dem
putschversuch einige tage in haft jede
kritik am regime werde bis heute als
terror unterstützung verleumdet und
verfolgt sagte nachdem der militärputsch
abgewendet worden war begann eine art
zivil ab otto hahn wollte seine macht
stärken das präsidialsystem wurde
eingeführt seitdem herrscht eine art
dauer ausnahmezustand und wir sehen eine
schwächung der demokratischen
institutionen
doch es gibt kritik am autoritären
führungsstil des präsidenten auch in der
eigenen partei vor allem wegen dessen
wirtschafts und finanzpolitik je
schlimmer die wirtschaftskrise wurde
desto unzufriedener wurden die leute und
desto wütender wurde erdogan während der
korona krise ist seine popularität noch
weiter zurückgegangen
der präsident versucht von krisen
abzulenken indem er seinem volk immer
neue großtaten präsentiert vor kurzem
gab er den startschuss zum bau eines
neuen kanals zwischen schwarzem und
marmarameer
in istanbul ist einen neuen flughafen
einen gigantischen fernsehturm und vor
allem moscheen bauen
für den stadtplaner aktiv abler sind
solche projekte politische zeichen
erdogan sun seine
konservativ-islamischen wähler und nicht
nur das diese projekte kann man nicht
nur mit politischen motiven erklären sie
sind auch wirtschaftlich sehr lukrativ
und zwar für die baulobby unternehmen
die durch solche projekte von der
regierung bedient und ernährt über die
verbindung von politik wirtschaft und
organisiertem verbrechen berichtet ein
bekannter mafiaboss auf youtube postet
apk seit wochen bekennervideos seine
enthüllungen über dubiose geschäfte von
regierungsmitgliedern und deren familien
unland kaum noch jemanden im land viele
sehen darin gar den anfang vom ende
die prächtigsten paläste des osmanischen
reiches wurden währenddessen niedergang
gebaut der dolmar budget palast entstand
obwohl man die eigenen soldaten nicht
mehr bezahlen konnte
man wollte den leuten sagen schaut wir
haben geld und wir sind stark aber das
sind alles anzeichen von verfall und
machtverlust
fünf jahre nach dem putschversuch ist
die türkische gesellschaft gespalten und
sie können davon berichten hunderte von
opfern der säuberungswelle erzählen ihre
geschichten auf dem youtube-kanal von k
k tv auch mit erkern mit den damals per
dekret entlassenen eine stimme geben
der journalist wurde von der staatlichen
nachrichtenagentur gefeuert beweise
gegen ihn gab es keine seinen job bekam
er bis heute nicht zurück doch er wird
behandelt wie ein aussätziger meine
nachbarn wollen nichts mehr mit mir zu
tun hat selbst viele meiner freunde
haben sich von mir distanziert wenn ich
etwas post oder in den sozialen medien
ein foto ein stelle werden diese dinge
nicht mehr von meinen damaligen freundin
kommentiert
heute findet ahmet den ehemaligen
verwaltungsbeamten ärger als herb kaya
der hält sich seit jahren mit einem
hausmeister job über wasser herder
gehört zu den wenigen die offen vor der
kamera reden viele haben angst früchten
die reaktionen der nachbarn oder
nachteile bei ihren gerichtsverfahren
herr doll aber ist das egal
ich schäme mich nicht weil ich diese
arbeit mache denn irgendwie muss ich für
meinen unterhalt sorgen
aber meine diplom die nutzen wir gar
nichts mehr die ausbildung die ich habe
kann nicht wegwerfen
sie haben für firmen der gülen-bewegung
gearbeitet sind auf den schulen gegangen
doch terroristen sagen sie sind wir
deshalb nicht wir wurden in kollektiv
haft genommen ohne beweise für den
putsch in den 80er jahren wurden später
zwei leute verurteilt ein putschversuch
von 2016 wurden hunderttausende vor
gericht gestellt das ist doch verrückt
sie machen das um ihre eigene autorität
zu sterben
sie nutzen den putsch immer noch für
ihre eigenen zwecke der gülle mist und
juni will die linke gewerkschafterin
sie fühlen sich als opfer eines
politischen machtkampfs eines
machtkampfs der hunderttausenden
oppositionellen die berufliche und
soziale existenz nahm und der die
türkische gesellschaft tief spaltet bis
heute
[Musik]